AN WITH BREAKING NEWS
THE DOW DRNG TODAY CNG
SELL-O FLEE COVID-19 DELTA HEINS
RYE IN. E TO SO NYOFERICANG
IN THE VIRUSL HURT THE.
ECONOMICRLINES SUCH ASD,D ICE H
WHAT ELSE OTHER
COMPANIES TIED TOMIC UCH ASAL
AND CATERPILLAR.
THS US TO OUR HEALTH
LE TM
H ASES
HOSPIZNS
UPN THE UNITEDTATES. DTHPEOPLE .
S. SURGE GS
HE'S STILLRIED ABOUT WHAT'S TOG
TES AND MISINFORMA, LIES
ABOUT THVAE RUNNIN
ANNOE LEARN
ATHLETRENG IN CONNECTIITH THE
OLYMPIC GAMES IN,
INCLUDINE U.S. S GYMNASTICS
HAS NO SPTT THS LIE  OPENINGLDES
PERNICIOUSNESS OF THA
STRAIN AND THED TO GET
WE'RE COVERING THIS STORY FROM .
LET'S STT RICA HRE IN THE ST.ER
>> Reporter: THAT'S GHGUIDANCE
OUT TODAY FROM T AACADEMOFICWHH
RECOMMENDSHA R AND STAF TO MASK
GA OF VACCINATION
STATUS.
AN REASONS THETE TGE
T PU12 WHO ARE NOT YET
ELIGIBLE FOR THE VACCINE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTETHOUGH,
THIS IS WHERE YOIT
CDC.
ITS SC GUIDANCE RECOMMENDETHAT
AND STAFF DIDN'TUE MASKING UT'SF
SOME O CDC GUIDANCON THE STREET.
>> THOSE THAT AR
ARE THOSE WHO ARE VACCINATED.
HO
>> MOSETTHO INATED.
BEEN
PREVIOUSLY
OR THEY WILL GET TDELT
DERIR MOSTPL
USIN THEIR DELTA-FUEING NEW CASN
, T O EK
INME HOSPITALIZATIONS RISING AT.
STNOS AFTER THE JU 4 F HAVE YE .
IN MISSISSIPPIT' THALF.
ON'T GET ANIFICANTTHESE RECALCNT
PEOPLE VACCID,G
E ERING OF
IS OUTBR
A D OF TIME.
>> W 12 ST
, THE
AMER AF PEDIATRICS
ONUDENTS
2 ANR ANST
CONTINUE TO HOOL.
SURGE
GIRET  OCE, TWEETING
THE VISEAMERICANS TOQU IT AN
REASH RISING
CASE
AND PRESIDENIDENT BIDEN
CEBOOK'S ROLE THE SPREAD OF >>
WEEK THAT COMPANIES AN
EBOOK AR>> FACING
LISTENING TO IT IS E NGRMATION.
GETTING HURT BY IT
MY HOP THAT FA INSTEAD
OF TAKING  PERSONALLY THAT
W I'M SAYING FACOOK ISINPE THEY
MISINFORMATION.
>> Repor WITH SO MUCMIE MAY BE .
E OTE ON MASKSER
IN NEW YORK CIOR BILL de
BLASIO WAS ASKED AGAINAY
ABOUTHE POSSIBILITY  AASNDATE R.
HE SAIS RIGHT NOW,, IS ON IN
DOWO T
THE ROOT OF THE PROBM.ING TO CIR
53% OF THE T POPULATION OF
NE
VAED.
> IN TOKYO THE ASES LINKED TO
OLYMPIC GAS  NOW 61,
MEWHO WERE
VING IYMC
LET'S BRING  WL RIPLEY
LIVE FOR US FROM TMEE FRIDAY.
WHAT ARE OFFICIALS SAYING ER OS?
>> T DOWNPLAYING
THEY ARE POINTING OUTHE
THAN2,AVE ARRIVED
REMBER,
IS ITHEIR  BTHHALF OF THOSE 61 H
OTHORSE EHE AT THE T OR ILIKE
THAT U.S. MNT KA EER
FROMCITYSER
VACCINATEHED POSITICAMP OF
>> I KNOW SHE'S OINTED, THIT
KIND OF BORED BECAUSE SHE'S
UC ROOO DO
SO SS BOD ST
IN COMINMEINE KES HER OUT OF I
COMPLETE.
>>AL HIGH-PRE ATHL
HAVE HAD TDRMENOR TE
ORO COVID PROTOCOLG 17-YEAR-OLDS
DENSY PACKED A
WHERE SOMETIME
OPMENT WITH
FOUR PEOE TO AAT
BREEDING GROUID
OUTB.AT'S WHY ATHLETEE  E
THEY'RE TOLD THEY HAVE TO WEAR
'R COMPETING
TING AND DRINKING.
SO OBVIOUS TA
CHANCE FOR THINGS TO BE SPREAD
IN THAALTH EXPERT WAS YING
AND THAT IS RAISING AME.IANT HA
SUPERSPREADER EVENT HERE.
>> WILL, THAOUCHLET'S DISCUSS A
DR JHA, THE DEAN
PULET'S START IN TOKYO. OF
MORE THAPLE HAVE TESTE
POVEON TE
CS
E 61 PEOPLE,
WHETHER THEY HAVE
WHETHER THE , JUST
THBETTER, T EN IT COMES
ELOADS AT THE OLYMPICS?
>> JAKE.
I WAS HOPING IT WOULD BE BS
WETITO GO
BEFORE THE GAMES BEGIN.
AND I A LOT OF UWORRIED, GIVEN N
VAED PEOPLE THERE ARE ATST E TH
SEE MORE SPREA T
>> NO REQUIR WEEK AS
TH AATBITO TOK ON ES NOT TO GO
AROUND HND SO PUBLIC AND D LARG.
ATEALLY WORRIED ABOU
ATED ATHLETES
AND OT WHO BEING IN THAT PLACE.E
ESIZATIOANNG ARE FROM CC
I THINK 97% OF
DE.HEARING ABOUT MORE GH JUST O.
ERNED?LE BE
>> SO, LARGELY NO.
ME
MAY FEEL LOUSY FOR A COF
HOSPITALIZATION AND DEATH THAT
'V FROM THIS
VIRUS.
AND YOU ARHAOM THE.
SO I THINKNOT BE
CONCERNED.
AND WE'VE RE GO PUT ALL
OF OUR ETSN GETTING MORE
PEACCINATED.
>> OF THE NF ON THE
VACCINES COME FROM2 PEOPLE NOW
WHAT DO YOU K  BEST ADING LIES T
WATOMI>> YEAH.
PLAGUE OF OUR TIMES.HAS A BIPONB
LOOK TOUS THAT EBOOK HAS KNOW
PLATFORM.U DON'T HAVE TGI 'T HAO